Edinburgh is inspiring the skyline of
the new town is as picturesque as the
silhouette of the castle rising about
the old town almost wherever you go in
Edinburgh you have a view the Scottish
capitals entire city centre is a unesco
world cultural heritage site and
Edinburgh is not just the political hub
of Scotland but the creative one as well
especially for writers one of them is
poet Christine DeLuca she's been
appointed the city barred or Makka we
have a very rich literary tradition and
I think wherever you go it's like being
in an open-air Museum really if you take
this court here this courtyard Mackers
court and the very flagstones come alive
with the words of the writers the great
writers they have to be dead to be here
but it's you can't forget them when you
walk through here traces of Scotland's
literary tradition are everywhere poet
Robert Ferguson captured a day in this
city in the 18th century there's a
statue dedicated to him Ferguson also
influenced Scotland's most famous bard
Robert Burns reminders of the ploughman
poet can be found all over the city one
is a classical Greek memorial erected in
Burns's honor but there's an even bigger
monument to author sir walter scott his
historical novel Ivanhoe is considered a
classic the world over Scott also helped
promote a romanticized identity for his
homeland making kilts and tartan once
again popular
you
and everyone also knows the novel
Treasure Island by Robert Louis
Stevenson the author and poet spent much
of his early life in this house in
Edinburgh Zoo town Stevenson lived here
in the mid 19th century today the house
belongs to felicitous and john mcphee
they live here but regularly rent out
two rooms two guests as gospel Olson
students as a guest here with us in the
Stevenson house you have a unique
opportunity to live in the childhood
home of Robert Louis Stevenson and you
can breathe in the atmosphere and see
how one of Scotland's most famous
writers lived on a table room doesn't
rub Stella short landscaped at Edinburgh
is literary scene is still lively today
it said that JK Rowling of harry potter
Fame wrote the first book in the series
looking out on edinburgh castle from
this cafe Christine DeLuca comes here
often to
I can see are sitting here biting quite
easily anybody is a very small city in
many ways and a very intimate city and
it's a city of many cities with lots of
history and I think walking around that
you can be inspired they'll walk up to
the castle down the Royal Mile and you
see the all-city some say rolling
modeled the magician's boarding school
Hogwarts on edinburgh castle
outside Edinburgh there are other sites
that have inspired Scottish authors
robert scott's work immortalized the
ruins of Tantallon Castle and Robert
Louis Stevenson set his novel Catriona
at bass rock
when night draws in the pubs and bars in
Edinburgh is old town see plenty of
custom after all in many places visitors
can choose from around 300 different
types of scotch whisky after a long day
of looking at heart which is what we did
today in the rain in the rain and
walking around it's good to have whiskey
to warm you up a little bit the Scots
are very proud of their whiskey Robert
Burns often used a wee dram or two to
fire up his creativity in one of his
poems he even wrote that freedom and
whiskey gang together